[Music]
the family goes in this court seeking
justice
for all of us in america
america and the rest of the world have
been waiting for the trial of derek
chauvin the former police officer
accused of killing george floyd over the
next half hour we'll bring you testimony
from the witnesses who've given evidence
during the first week of proceedings
first though the trial began with
opening statements by the prosecution
and the defense and a warning the
evidence contains graphic images and
descriptions
of the death of george floyd on may 25th
of 2020 mr derrick chavin
betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
that he put his knees upon his neck and
his back
grinding and crushing him until
the very breath no ladies and gentlemen
until the very life
was squeezed out of him you will learn
that he was well aware that mr floyd was
unarmed that mr floyd had not threatened
anyone that mr floyd was in handcuffs he
was completely in the control of the
police
he was defenseless you will learn what
happened
in that nine minutes and 29 seconds the
most important numbers you were hearing
this trial at nine
to nine what happened in those nine
minutes and 29 seconds
when mr derek shavin was applying this
excessive force to the body of mr george
floyd
you will learn about things such as the
authorized use of force
proportionality of force excited
delirium
defensive tactics including prone
handcuffing
neck restraints maximal restraint
technique the swarm technique
you will learn about rapidly evolving
situations
and the minneapolis police department's
decision-making model
you will learn about crowd control
medical intervention
de-escalation procedural justice crisis
intervention
and the human factors of force that is
what happens to a police officer or any
person
when they are involved in a high-stress
use of force situation
and you will learn that derek shovin did
exactly
what he had been trained to do over the
course of his 19-year career
the use of force is not attractive
but it is a necessary component of
policing
darnella frazier was 17 when she
recorded the video of george floyd here
that went viral igniting international
protest at
racism and police abuse she didn't
appear on camera in court but
told the jury she feels regret for not
engaging physically with the officers
that day
but that ultimately they were the ones
at fault
he had like this cold look
heartless he didn't care it seemed it
seemed as if he didn't care
what we were saying it didn't change
anything he was
doing in response to what the proud was
doing or saying
did you see him at any time kneeling
harder on george floyd
in response yes did mr chavin
get off of mr floyd when the ambulance
arrived no
the ambulance person had to actually
tell him to lift up
when i look at george floyd i look at
i look at my dad i look at my brothers
i look at my cousins my uncles
because they are all black i have black
i have a black father i have a black
brother
i have black friends
and i i look at that and i look at how
that could have been one of them
it's the nights i stayed up
apologizing
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting
and not saving his life but it's like
it's not what i should have done it's
what he should have done
the court has played the audio of a
9-1-1 call made by witness and
mixed martial arts expert donald
williams he made that call
during george floyd's arrest here and
said he believed
he was witnessing a murder did
call the police on the police and why
did you do that
because uh i believe i witnessed a
murder
and so you felt a need to call the
police yeah i [ __ ] need to call the
police on the police
now there were police there right there
there were police there
okay why didn't you just talk to them
about it
i believe that they didn't i just we
just didn't have no connection
you know i spoke to them but not on a
connection of a human being
relationship if we count at this point
then play exhibit 20.
25 2000 20. 911
officer 987 killer uh citizen in front
of a chicago
uh store he just pretty much just killed
this guy
that wasn't resisting arrest he had his
knee on the dude neck the whole time
officer 987
the man when uh went stop breathing he
wasn't resisting the rush of nothing he
was already in handcuffs
they pretty much just killed the dude i
don't even know if he cared for sure but
he
was not responsible when the ambulance
just came and got him and the officer
that was just out here left
the one that actually just murdered his
feet in front of everybody on
36 38 in uh chicago okay would you like
to speak with the
sergeant yeah like that was bogus what
the court heard from an off-duty
firefighter who also called 911 that day
genevieve hansen said she begged police
officers on the scene
to let her check to see if george floyd
had a pulse
i tried different tactics of
calm and reasoning um
i tried to be assertive um
i i pled and was desperate
did you also at some point start raising
your voice yes sir
and maybe used some follow language even
yes sir why um because
i was desperate to help
and i
wasn't getting what i what i needed to
do
and gaining access and at some point
the voices of the other people around
you did you feel that sort of interfered
with
getting the officer's attention yes
um so as you're doing that
were you able to pay more attention or
any more attention to mr floyd and his
condition
i i wasn't i wasn't really
able to i i knew he needed help so at
that point it was just
getting in there christopher martin was
working as a cashier at cup
foods the shop police had been called to
after mr floyd was accused of using a
fake twenty dollar bill
to buy cigarettes when i um
saw the bill i noticed that it had a
blue pigment to it
kind of how a hundred dollar bill will
have
and i found that odd so i assumed that
it was fake
was it you who called the police about
it no was it another co-worker
correct and
did you ask the co-worker to make the
call
no and were you present when you made
the call correct
okay so you were there next to him or
something correct
we saw you standing there with your
hands on your head for a while correct
great
what was going through your mind during
that time period uh disbelief
thank god okay why guilt
um if i would have just not taken the
bill
this could have been avoided
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this week sky news has been
bringing continuous coverage and
analysis of the trial of derek chauvin
the former police officer accused of
killing george floyd
here in may last year we're looking back
at some of the testimony of those
called to the witness stand during the
first week of proceedings
and on day three the jury was shown new
police body camera footage of
george floyd pleading with officers
during his arrest
and a warning the evidence contains
graphic images and descriptions
of the death of george floyd
also seen in a cctv video from the same
time is 61 year old charles mcmillian
who appears to have been the first
bystander on the scene
of mr floyd's arrest jesus
christ
stop moving mama
mama
oh my god when he kept saying i can't
breathe
and when he said
mama they're killing me
and he they're killing me that's what
i kept hearing i can't breathe mama
they're killing me
then when you start saying my my body's
shutting down
and was it your voice
somewhere in the middle of all this
saying get up and get in the car
um was that you yes ma'am
and why were you saying that what were
you trying to do at that point
trying to help you and
how did he look to you after
this continued when you said he was
saying mama and i can't breathe how did
he appear to be to you
he appeared to be in and out with the
phone running at his mouth
did you remark about his foot on his
neck or something to that effect
i can't recall okay but if it's there
would be in the videos
all right and again some of these can be
difficult to hear can can we put up
exhibit 41 please
can you advise the fire department if
they're still with you they need to go
to 36 minutes
looks like he's probably on something
george floyd's girlfriend courtney ross
was the first person to testify
who personally knew mr floyd she offered
a picture of a man whose face of course
now is
known around the world and described the
first time they met
but has this great deep
southern voice raspy
and he's like sis you okay
and i wasn't okay
i said no i'm i'm i'm just waiting for
my son's father
he said um
what can i pray with
[Music]
i you i was so
tired and we've been through so much
my sons and i this kind person just to
come up to me and say can i pray with
you
when i felt alone in this lobby
it was so sweet
at that point did you know what mr floyd
was doing there
at the salvation army oh yes i'm sorry
he worked there as a security guard
and so he came up to you and tried to
comfort you yes
floyd and i uh both suffered with
opioid addiction and
do you know how i mean like for your own
self how it
how you came to be involved you know
with
what kind of drugs and how you became
opiates yes um
both floyd and i are our
our story uh it's
it's a classic story of
uh how many people get addicted to
opioids
we both suffered from chronic pain
mine was in my neck and his was in his
back
we both um had prescriptions
but um
after prescriptions
that were filled and uh
we we got addicted and
and tried really hard to
break that addiction many times
seth bravender was one of the paramedics
who treated george floyd
he told the jury that when he arrived on
the scene with his partner derek smith
mr floyd appeared unresponsive
i assumed that there was potentially
some struggle still because
they were still on top of them so that
was
my assumption when we pulled up so when
you got to the scene
having no additional information seeing
what you saw
that's what was going through your mind
is that right yes so when you
got to the scene what'd you do next
parked the ambulance
near the patient and got out i walked to
the back of the ambulance and my
partner walked over to check on the
patient
as you approached him to inspect further
were the officers still on top of him
the officers were still on him when i
approached and what did you do
when you approached i was
assessing the scene and running through
what
um care maybe needed and did you
take some initial steps like checking
for a pulse i checked for a pulse
and um did you also check
the individual mr floyd's pupils i did
and what did you
determine at that point they were large
dilated
so you determined that his pupils were
large and dilated what about a pulse
i did not elevate a pulse
when you say palpate is that you didn't
feel or detect a pulse do not detect
pulse and what did his condition appear
to be
to you overall in late terms
i thought he was dead
despite being at the center of a closely
watched trial the jurors and the public
at large
have heard very little from former
minneapolis police officer derek chauvin
but
on thursday they heard a call between
him and a supervisor reviewing the force
he'd used during the arrest
come on 2 30 here
yeah i was just uh gonna call you and
have you come out to our
scene here
um not really but we just had to have to
hold the guy down he was uh
was uh going crazy wasn't going
uh now for the moment wouldn't go in the
back of the uh
do you recognize the voice in that call
yes whose voice is that officer shulman
that was the conversation or at least
his end of the conversation
as you recall it on that day that you
just described yes
he made a reference to shutting off can
you explain to the jury what
that was in reference to i probably
asked him if he had his camera on or off
since we're having a private
conversation
and that would be within policy within
the body-worn camera policy for him to
shut off during the
during that conversation is that right
yes
did he tell you uh whether he personally
applied any particular type of force or
restraint to mr floyd i don't believe so
he'd tell you whether or not he had to
or other officers
pin mr floyd to the ground i think in
the conversation there he said something
about held somebody down
did he mention anything about putting
his knee on mr floyd's neck or back
no
sir based on your review of the body
worn camera footage
do you have an opinion as to when the
restraint of mr floyd
should have ended in this encounter yes
what is it when mr floyd was no longer
offering up any resistance to the
officers they could have
entered the restraint and that was after
he was handcuffed and on the ground
and no longer resistant correct thank
you
i have no further questions your honor
the final witness to take the stand was
the minneapolis police department's
longest serving officer
richard zimmerman
based on your review of the body-worn
camera videos of the incident
yes and directing your attention into
that moment when
mr floyd is placed on the ground yes
um what is your uh
you know your view of that use of force
during that time period
totally unnecessary what do you mean
well first of all
pulling him down to the ground face down
and putting your knee on the neck for
that amount of that amount of time
it's just uncalled for
i saw no reason why the officers felt
they were in danger
if that's what they felt um
and that's what they would have to feel
to be able to use that kind of force
so in your opinion should that restraint
have stopped once he was handcuffed
and prone on the ground absolutely
the first five days of this trial have
been about much more than just those
nine minutes and 29 seconds
footage not seen publicly before as
added to the picture of what happened
before and after george floyd died for
the jury
it is about what happened and why but
for millions of others it's about a
search for answers
the trial will resume on monday
you